get closer and closer to a government
shutdown President Trump is resolute
today he announced that border security
is a principle worth fighting for
take a look our nation has spent
trillions of dollars and sacrificed
thousands of brave young lives defending
the borders of foreign nations I am
asking Congress to defend the border of
our nation for tiny fraction tiny
fraction of the cost in life there are
certain principles worth fighting for
principles that are more important than
politics party or personal convenience
the safety and security and sovereignty
of the United States is the most
important principle of all if we don't
stand strong for our national borders
then we cease to be a nation and we
betray our commitment to the loyal
citizens of our great country now with
President Trump determined to fund the
border wall what will happen next in
Congress joining us from Capitol Hill
are two lawmakers who want wall funding
house freedom caucus members Joe Georgia
congressman excuse me Jody hice and from
Virginia's fifth District Tom Garrett
congressman thank you very much for
joining us I'll go to congressman hice
first congressman I know the house
freedom caucus has been doing an
excellent job fighting for principles up
there and I admire your resolute stance
on on on liberty freedom and immigration
control and border wolf funding but
what's going on with the establishment
Republicans why are they fighting this
we've had the majority for a long time
from your perspective what took so long
to get this done yeah dan really I don't
have any any idea - as to why many of us
have been calling for months and months
and months let's deal with this issue we
have the majority the American people
sent us here for this the president is
behind it let's let's go for it and for
whatever reason that's been stall after
stall after stall one CR after another
after another and at this this point
there was just a line drawn in the sand
it was like we've had enough we're no
longer taking this you know it was it
reminds me Dan down in the Alamo there's
a monument there but the monument is not
there because they won the fight is
there because they fall and that really
it was the line that was drawn in the
sand with us over the last
24 hours and it's turned out to just be
as absolutely spectacular 24 hours both
for the freedom caucus for our
conference as a whole for the president
and for our country
you know congressman Garrett the
Republicans have out there the activists
the people knocking on the doors
donating the money doing the actual work
that are sweating out there in the
summer trying to get people in Congress
on the Republican side elected they've
been disappointed before repeatedly now
to the credit the tax credit the tax cut
bill was excellent but the Obamacare
failure and other things I see this is a
political red line and one of those
moments where we absolutely have to
stand up for something do you feel the
same way are you getting the same thing
from your constituents you know look one
of the reasons that you're lucky you
didn't win when you ran for congress is
it's disgusting to be in a town where a
bunch of people make promises that they
don't intend to keep and some of us
congressman hice and myself haven't
equivocated let me be real clear the
cost in human lives straight-line cost
of not protecting our border would equal
the casualties in the Korean War over a
decade over 10% of drunk drivers here
illegally that's thousands of deaths a
year 4,000 murders a year if you then
figure and illicit drugs they come to
this country and kill our brothers and
sisters and sons and daughters and so
this is truly about protecting America I
am for a robust and healthy immigration
plan but it is ridiculous and it flies
in the face of a sovereign nation not to
do this it's tragic that it had to be
done this way now I agree a congressman
high sells this exit question with you
here you know the GOP loses Republicans
lose when we don't advance our
principles I said this last night
ironically the Democrats lose when they
advance there's right Barack Obama did
did everything to decimate the Democrat
Party and help Iraq Obama what do you
think is going to happen on the Senate
side I understand we probably don't have
the votes to overcome a filibuster but
are there enough moderate Democrats on
the Senate side to get this push through
it's a reasonable bill yeah it is a
reasonable bill and it's a great
question and the truth of the matter
look look we've already seen the the
Schumer shut down a few weeks ago we're
about to see the Schumer Senate shut
down again because we're sending him a
reasonable bill that defends our borders
protects American citizens I mean who
would not be in favor of that and five
billion dollars when you compare that to
1.3 trillion that we have in our annual
budget I mean we're talking like a day a
day and a half of our budget to build
this wall for security and the truth of
the matter is the Senate did not vote on
this bill that they sent us it they
passed it by voice vote so we don't know
where the Senate is going to be on this
but I the the the reality is now they're
either going to fund this well they're
going to shut down the government and I
just don't that's a tough choice for
them to be in right now
this five point seven billion dollars
dan is actually in less than one day
it's about a half a day right and I'm
tired of fixing the blame let's start
fixing the problem we in the house
should do our jobs and if the clowns on
the other side of the building wanna
fail let them but but when we say well
it won't get through the Senate so we're
gonna abdicate our responsibility I just
won't accept that
yeah congressman Garrett I like your
style I like you to congressman house
you're good many thanks for joining us
thanks for fighting in your fight guys